this is the 72nd annual Academy Awards
it's a highly-charged seen here at the
Shrine Auditorium is tonight's Oscar
hopefuls greets fans and reporters along
the red carpet everyone is wondering who
will take home film's highest honor
Michael Clarke Duncan nominated for his
first Oscar tonight winner last year for
Shakespeare in Love Dame Judi Dench
Michael Caine nominated for the spider
House Rules
the music world's hottest stars taking
part in Hollywood's biggest night Kate
Hill Gloria Estefan Phil Collins
from The Cider House Rules Charlize
Theron's Oscar winner Kevin Spacey he's
nominated tonight for American Beauty
nominated four boys don't cry Hilary
Swank from PricewaterhouseCoopers great
garrison and Lisa Piazza carrying the
envelopes with tonight's winners Oscar
winner Roberto Benigni Best Actor
nominee Denzel Washington Ethan Hawke
and uma Thurman sir of the upcoming film
rules of engagement Samuel l jackson
stalks the army Archerd
reporter Tom
beautiful Salma Hayek Norton The Spy Who
shagged me Mike Myers
there's something about Mary star
Cameron
chow yun-fat Best Actress nominee is
Meryl Streep and Julianne Moore now
let's go inside
Oh
as we celebrate the 72nd annual Academy
Awards welcome the president of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences producer Bob Rainey
good evening and welcome to the 72nd
annual Academy Awards
well it's certainly been an interesting
year or at least an interesting last few
weeks in which to focus in Hollywood
shifted from who in the world is going
to win the least predictable year in
memory - what in the world are we going
to present them with but all the Oscars
and all of the stars are here tonight
and we're ready for our annual
celebration now the Academy president on
these occasions is more or less expected
to beam about what a great year for
movies the one just past has been 1999
actually brought us a gratifying supply
of good big pictures and wonderful
little ones inventive studio films and
imaginative independence and some
animated and documentary features that
seem likely to become classics tonight
we'll find out which of them were most
admired by the distinguished filmmakers
from around the world who make up the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences so it's time to get started
with our job for 2000 it's late March
we've already seen a quarter of the
movies we'll be judging next year and
it's not even too early to ask what
might we see in 2001